-Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-I always love to see --
Yeah, we love you.
I always love seeing you, pal.
I want to say congratulations.
You co-wrote and directed
your first movie.
-I did.
-This is a big deal.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Alright.
What is it called and what
can you tell us about it?
-It's called "Hell of a Summer."
It's like a slasher horror
but -- with a lot of blood.
But it also has -- It's supposed
to be funny, so I hope it is.
-Yeah. I think you can do both.
-Yeah.
-Were you nervous
about directing or...?
-Definitely, but I also --
I've always wanted to be, like,
making films
since I was really little.
And now
I'm a little less little.
-Yeah.
-So, it makes -- Yeah.
I feel like it makes sense.
-Did you talk to
the Duffer brothers and say,
"Hey, give me some advice.
What do I do?"
These guys are masters.
-Yeah, totally.
-Writing and directing.
-Yeah, I texted them,
and I was like, "Do you guys
ever get imposter syndrome still
when you're directing?"
And they were like, "Yeah."
So they still get...
-So, if they get it --
Then, yeah.
-Then we're good.
-But you're also acting in it.
-Yeah.
-So you're better
than the Duffer brothers.
-No, no, no, no, no.
Well, actual--
You know, maybe --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-'Cause they don't act.
-You know what?
-Yeah.
-The Duffer brothers have never
acted in their own stuff.
And that's why
I'm better than them.
-Yes! Exactly right!
Thank you! Finally!
You can say it on this show!
-That's not actually true
because when I was acting in it,
I was like,
"Man, this is going so well."
Then I got into the edit room,
and I realized --
I was, like, watching it,
and I was like,
"Whoa.
I'm not acting in that shot.
I'm not acting in that shot."
It's just basically me
watching the movie like this.
-You're reading the lines?
-Yeah.
I'm, like, mouthing people --
I'm mouthing along
with people's lines.
-You couldn't get out
of your director...
-No, apparently not.
-Oh, my gosh.
-So, yeah, I don't know
if I could maybe do that again.
-Dude, I'm excited.
I can't wait.
When that comes out,
please come on the show.
We'll talk about it.
-Thank you. I'd love to.
-I haven't seen you
since season four
of "Stranger Things" came out.
Congratulations.
It's the biggest thing
in the world.
-Thank you.
-So well done.
-Thanks.
-And kudos to the whole cast
and the Duffers, as well.
And season five -- this is
the last season coming up.
-Yeah.
Are you nervous, excited, sad,
or just waiting
for all those emotions?
-It's going to be crazy
once it's all done.
I'm just excited to go back
and actually finish it.
-They released the name
of the first episode.
-Yeah.
-It's called "The Crawl."
-I'm not even joking. I found
out about that yesterday.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-So you don't know?
They just did it,
and you go, "Oh, when are you
guys going to tell me?"
-No, and I think a lot of people
don't believe it
because it just is, like,
they don't --
"Of course you know.
You're on the show."
But, like, they're really --
they're super cagey.
-Yeah. For a good reason.
-I guess so, yeah.
Or else I'd go blabbing
on "The Tonight Show."
-Yeah. Exactly.
But I heard also that you --
You have a creative brain.
You have a very artistic brain,
a great brain.
And I think you said, as a joke
to someone on the staff
or on the crew -- You were
doing "Stranger Things."
You go, "You should do a
spin-off of blah, blah, blah."
And you said something,
and they were like,
"You're kind of right."
-Well, yeah.
So, we were on set filming
"Stranger Things 4."
And we were all
talking about, like, yeah,
if there's going to be, like --
Like, joking.
"Oh, they're all going to
have us back in 20 years.
We're all going to be,
like, fat and old
and being like,
'Oh, Evan, where are you?'"
You know, that kind of thing.
And then I was like,
"Oh, but, if you guys are
actually going to do a spin-off,
it should be this."
And I said it,
and the Duffers, like,
looked at each other and looked
at me, and they were like,
"Could we talk to you
for a second?"
And then they pulled me off
and they were like,
"That is the idea.
Who told you?"
I was like, "No one."
They were like,
"What do you mean?
You just, like,
came up with it?"
And I was like, "Well, no,
I just thought that that
would be a cool way
to kind of expand..."
And they were like...
-It is.
-Yeah. They were like,
"Well, yeah, I don't know."
And they were like --
Yeah, it was really funny.
They were like,
"Okay, well, don't tell anyone."
[ Laughter ]
-"And it's our idea."
-Yeah, exactly.
-I want to talk
about your new movie.
It's called "When You Finish
Saving the World."
It was written and directed
by Jesse Eisenberg.
Gosh, we love that guy.
-Yeah, he's one of the best.
-Oh, my gosh. He's brilliant.
How did you get involved
with this one?
-Jesse had written
an Audible Original
sort of, like, a --
kind of audiobook play
sort of thing and put me in it.
And it was based on that.
The movie is based on that.
-Yeah.
It's with Julianne Moore.
It's about this kind of
mother and son
who are complete opposites.
Yeah. I don't know.
It's an honor to be a part of.
-You also play, like,
an aspiring musician in this.
-Yes.
-And, really in real life,
you are a musician.
You're a great musician,
by the way.
I was telling you --
I was listening to you
on Spotify earlier today.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-You wrote some of the songs
for this?
-Yeah, I helped write
some of the songs.
There's like two or three songs
in the movie that I wrote,
but they're less important.
They're the sort of shallow,
bad ones, and then --
-No, it's great. They're great.
-No, but then the great ones --
Like, Emile Mosseri,
who's one of the greatest
living film composers,
helped, you know --
wrote it with Jesse.
And Jesse did the lyrics
and everything.
But, yeah, no, it was amazing
to sort of do both.
Like, be kind of treated
as a collaborator.
-Does that change your --
the way you write your songs,
meeting these composers?
-Yeah, definitely. I remember
just being like, "Oh, man.
How similar
are my songs to this,
like, really arrogant
kid's songs?"
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so I started comparing --
The guy that I play,
his name is, like, Ziggy.
And he's, like,
this pretty sweet kid
but also super-obnoxious
and arrogant.
And, you know,
he writes these songs
and plays them live
on the Internet
kind of like
on a TikTok platform.
But, like, no one cares
in real life about him
or about what he's doing.
So he's always just like,
"Yeah, so, I have
like 20,000 followers,
so it's pretty cool."
And everyone's like,
"We don't care, dude."
-Yeah.
-But it was very --
Yeah, it's great.
-What is it?
It's under Ziggy Katz?
-Yeah, Ziggy Katz.
-Ziggy Katz is what
I was listening to today.
-K-A-T-Z.
-And the song?
-It's called "Pieces of Gold."
-Just check it out.
It's so good.
Dude, I love it, top to bottom.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Finn Wolfhard in "When
You Finish Saving the World."
Take a look at this.
-♪ That's the way
the earthquake crumbles ♪
-Hello?!
[ Drill whirs ]
What the hell are you doing?
-Installing a red beacon light
so people know
when I'm live-streaming.
-And by "people," you mean...
-I mean you.
-Well, I figured that, yes.
-And to a lesser extent, Dad.
-Well, it's nice to be first.
-Yeah, so,
when this light is on,
you don't knock or come in
or make any noise.
-Oh, and when it's off, I am --
I'm free to go
about my business,
to enjoy the rich
pageantry of life?
-What? Yeah, sure.
-It's a good system.
-Yeah! Julianne Moore.
We love her.
Finn Wolfhard, everybody.
"When You Finish
Saving the World"
is in theaters everywhere
January 20th.
Meghann Fahy joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.